[MUSIC PLAYING]
[WATER SPLASHING]
ERENA SHIMODA: So
today, you are going
to learn how to sink underwater
because I want to take you
to my underwater world.
No, don't hold your
breath like that
because you won't sink down
into the water like this.
All puffed up like a puffer
fish, holding in all that air,
you will bob up to the
surface like a duck toy.
Being underwater is a
transforming experience,
and I want to yours
to be beautiful.
But you can't get
there if you're
hanging on to fear, doubt,
and things you don't need.
So you need to
learn how to let go.
Let's do this together.
Inhale and exhale
with a count of five.
And when you exhale,
make sure you
exhale all the way
until you empty lungs
before you inhale again.
Ready?
Inhale.
[INHALES] Your lungs
expanding, and exhale.
[EXHALES]
Inhale and exhale
as slow as you can.
Your heart rate will slow down.
Everything will slow down.
You are learning to let go
of your breath and fear.
And you are learning to trust
your body and the water.
Let's do this one more time.
Inhale.
[INHALES] And exhale.
[EXHALES] You are
learning to let go.
[SINGING IN JAPANESE]
That means "the ocean is wide,
the ocean is huge" in Japanese.
I used to sing that song
in this inflatable pool
and pretend that
I was a mermaid.
Raise your hand.
Who wants to be a mermaid?
Good, good.
Merman?
Good.
I wanted to be a mermaid
and live underwater.
I was born and raised in Japan.
My father took us to the
ocean almost every summer
right outside Tokyo.
1989, we moved to the US.
One summer, we were in
a terrible car accident.
I was thrown out the car,
sent to ICU by helicopter,
fractured my entire body, and
I had a major brain injury.
I almost lost my life.
But instead, I lost my father,
who was in the driver's seat.
It was a miracle I survived
after all those injuries.
My family and friends tell me
that my father protected me,
and I am a survivor
for a reason.
At the time, I didn't
know what it really meant.
But I felt a huge
pressure because I
didn't want my father's
death to be in vain.
Years later, I
discovered scuba diving,
and I found out that I had a
talent for being underwater.
Because I was good at breathing,
I was in the water longer
than everybody else.
I felt like I belong here.
I'm almost mermaid.
That same year, I
went to Venezuela
and became a dive master.
I started taking
pictures of marine life.
I absolutely love
the underwater world.
Scuba diving and underwater
photography became my passion.
One day, I read that
scuba diving and swimming
can be alternative medicines
for anxieties and depressions.
I was actually struggling with
my depression at that time.
I could not get out from
my room or talk to anyone.
I felt anxious, angry,
and frustrated, and sad.
I was not being myself, and it
was getting worse day by day.
And I knew I had
to look for help.
I saw a psychologist,
psychiatrist, and therapist.
Nobody knew what
caused my depression.
I also have no family history.
Maybe the chemical imbalance
from my brain injury.
I was on medications
for over a year,
and I was not feeling
better at all.
And I even felt worse.
So I wanted to believe in these
articles about scuba diving
and swimming because it was
my only hope to get better.
And I remember when I
scuba dive, all the worries
and angers I can let go.
It's like water sets me free.
When I'm touched by
water from 360 degrees,
I can't feel this peaceful
energy swelling into my body.
This is my meditation space.
I can be myself and be free.
Since scuba diving is not
easily accessible for me,
I pushed myself to go
swimming every day.
I felt better
almost immediately,
and I dropped those medications
for being underwater.
That's why I love
creating images
with people underwater,
because underwater portrait
photography has the same
psychological benefits,
and I am able to share that
experience with my clients
underwater.
Everything is different.
The lighting, the
shapes, the sounds.
The subject's hair, face,
and dress move underwater.
Everything's slow and peaceful.
It's like you're dreaming.
What's going to
happen underwater?
I never know.
And it's challenging.
I love that mystery.
And underwater portrait
photography became my passion.
I've been underwater
photographer for over 10 years.
And back in 2013, I
launched a campaign
called Underwater
Healer About Face
to help cancer
survivors rediscover
their beauty through underwater
portrait photography.
Ever since, I donate
my time and reach out
to survivors of cancer,
domestic violence,
people with PTSD and
physical disabilities.
This project is
so important to me
because I love to see the
beautiful and mysterious
transformations that
happen underwater.
I want to give back
to the community
and spread this project
all over the world.
I've met so many
survivors who have
shared the powerful stories.
And I want to show you some of
the subject I've worked with.
This is Drina.
When she was eight years
old, she almost drowned.
Ever since, she hasn't
been in the water
deeper than her knee level.
She contacted me to do
this underwater maternity
photo shoot because she wanted
to overcome her fear by doing
this beautiful photo project.
In the beginning,
she was terrified.
Within 20 minutes, she
conquered her biggest fear,
and she couldn't stop crying
after the photo shoot.
Facing her fear helped
to release the trauma
she experienced as a child.
And this is her first time
ever underwater selfie shot.
She looks beautiful, right?
I have a client who
wants to stay anonymous.
PTSD she experienced
from domestic abuse
was much, much more
difficult than dealing
with breast cancer.
She was in a very
abusive relationship.
Thanks to the police
and her mother,
she finally got to escape.
But she was still scared
of dark and being alone,
and sought psychosomatic
help for her PTSD.
Now, she's in a healthy
relationship and got married.
But then she was diagnosed
with breast cancer.
During her treatment, she told
me that she went to islands.
She discovered water helped the
painful swelling in her body.
She also said underwater,
nobody judges her,
and she feels completely safe.
This is Chelsie.
When she was 17 years old,
she was in a car accident.
Her driver was drunk.
The car smashed into a tree--
crashed into a tree,
and the accident
damaged her spinal cord.
She's in the wheelchair
for the rest of her life.
This was not her first
time being in the water,
but it was her first time
completely submerging
underwater.
Also, it was her first time
opening her eyes and smile
at the same in the water.
Chelsea said it was a
challenging experience.
She found a new courage to
feel beautiful and strong.
And she also said
underwater, she
felt the freedom for not
relying on her wheelchair.
This is Jared.
He's an army veteran.
During his service
in Afghanistan,
his right arm was blown off.
He has PTSD, traumatic brain
injury, chronic phantom limb
pain, and shrapnel
still in his body.
After he had discovered
scuba diving,
he found out that
underwater is the only place
that he doesn't feel any pain.
Ocean is his therapy, and
water means peace, tranquility,
and freedom.
He is also a member of Dive
Warriors, the organizations who
helps disabled veterans
with scuba diving.
The day after the
photo shoot with Jared,
the Dive Warriors took
me out to go scuba dive
in Catalina Island.
It meant a lot to me that
I was part of their lives,
even just for one day.
We have different
backgrounds and disabilities.
But underwater, we were all
equal, safe, and pain free.
I cannot wait to meet them
underwater in the future again.
The last survivor I want
to introduce you to today
is Laurie, a breast
cancer survivor.
I'm going to play this video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hi.
My name is Laurie Ratliff.
I am a breast cancer survivor.
I was diagnosed almost 30 years
ago with metastatic breast
cancer.
And doing this underwater
photo shoot with Erena
was pretty wonderful.
It was exciting, but
relaxing and fun.
And she made the
whole process amazing.
Thank you.
[END PLAYBACK]
ERENA SHIMODA: She is
in the audience today.
And you will get to meet
her just in a moment.
And if you're ever
curious and brave to jump
in the water with me,
come talk to me right
outside after the presentation.
I can give you a
special discount,
and a portion of
your session fee
will go towards this campaign
for survivors like Chelsie,
Jared, and Laurie.
At the conference like ICEBAT,
International Conference
on Evidence Based
Aquatic Therapy,
I meet people who study the
benefits of total immersion.
For centuries in India,
China, throughout Europe,
people go into the water
to feel whole again.
Medical science knows
that total immersion
has the profound benefits.
Nervous, cardiovascular,
musculoskeletal,
and immune systems are
improved with hydrotherapies.
But I'm most interested
in how water reconnects us
to who we really are.
Water reminds us
of our wholeness
and restores us psychologically.
Medical science is beginning to
measure the positive and life
changing effects
of total immersion,
specifically psychological
effects that water has on us.
I'm most interested in
working with the scientists
at the forefront
of this research.
If you know any scientists,
psychologists, a PhD student
who would be interested
in this topic, please
let me know because I am
available to work together.
My family and friends tell me
I am a survivor for a reason.
Remember I told you
about the depression
and nobody knew what
triggered my brain?
And I went swimming every day.
I finally figured it out.
I can not lie or
hide underwater.
Water makes me honest.
So I'll tell you the truth.
I haven't told
anybody at the time,
but the day of the car accident,
I was actually driving first.
I got tired, so I asked my
father to switch with me.
He was also tired after working
long hours for the family.
But of course, he
wouldn't say no.
I wish I didn't have to ask him.
I could have saved his life.
My guilt was huge, and I
didn't know how to handle it.
I still have regrets and angers.
But being underwater
helps me let go of that.
I cannot change the past, but
what I can do is to give back
to the community and
make my father proud.
As an artist, I am
fascinated with the process
of capturing that moment when
we let go and remember that we
are strong, loved, safe.
Underwater, we can all
let go of our regrets
and remember who we really are.
I think we are all
survivors for a reason.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And now, I can bring in Laurie,
a breast cancer survivor.
And we can do Q and A.
LAURIE RATLIFF:
Slight correction
on the video that she showed.
I'm actually a 20
year cancer survivor.
I'd been talking with her just
before that about how long
I'd been married, which
was almost 30 years.
So that kind of slipped out.
My mother died from breast
cancer when I was 23.
And when I was
diagnosed at 34, I
decided that I was not going to
be quiet about it like she was.
It happens to so
many more people
than you realize that I
was going to talk about it.
And so I had been
talking about it
for the past 20 years to
anybody who will listen,
because especially when
I was first diagnosed,
I really didn't have much
contact with anybody.
I didn't know anybody like me.
And then as the
internet began to grow
and people began to put
more things out there,
I began to see images
of women like me
that I wished I had
seen in the beginning.
So there are several
photography projects
that people have done called
the Scar Project, the Grace
Project.
And I'd seen those pictures
and just been entranced by them
and realized I'm
only getting older.
So if I want to do
something different,
if I want to be
brave, now's the time.
And this is something
that I can say that--
I've seen underwater
photos and thought
they were beautiful,
but thought, "Oh, no.
Not me."
But then decided, "Yeah, me."
So I Googled [LAUGHS] breast
cancer photography portraits,
whatever.
And the very first
thing that came up
was Erena with underwater.
And I said, "That's it.
That's what I'm going to try."
And so I contacted her and
pretty quickly, we set it up.
And it was harder
than I thought.
It was easier than I thought.
It was a lot more
fun than I thought.
And I would love to
do it every month.
I'd love to go back and do it.
Just like she was
saying, that sense
of being underwater, the
calmness, the support.
Because over the years,
treatment and cancer
can take a lot of
toll on your body.
There's a lot of
collateral damage.
So the past 15 years, I've
dealt with some really serious
chronic pain issues
and mobility.
And way long ago, I
used to be a dancer.
And I don't get to
do that anymore.
And what I discovered
is going underwater,
I can feel like I
can dance again.
ERENA SHIMODA: Yeah.
And looking at her toes,
pointy toes, she's a dancer.
[LAUGHS] It's
beautiful underwater.
AUDIENCE: Laurie, would you mind
telling us a little bit more
about what the experience
was like the first time you
got into the water?
I am really curious
about what that
was like, what it was like
being photographed underwater
for the first time.
LAURIE RATLIFF: When
we started the session,
I actually had a dress on.
I was unsure if I wanted
to do a unclothed session.
I was-- Yeah.
That scared me a lot.
And obviously, I've had
a bilateral mastectomy.
I chose not to have
reconstruction.
And when I talked
to Erena about it,
she asked me if I would
be doing it topless.
And I was saying,
"I'm really not sure."
And she encouraged
me by saying that it
can help other women
to see somebody
like them if I did feel
comfortable enough doing it.
And that is exactly
what I wished I had had.
And so that kind of
tipped the scales.
But I started in a dress
because I was nervous.
And it feels very strange to
get in the water fully clothed.
But it was a warm pool.
And going underwater,
you can be very surprised
how buoyant you are.
So I would think I would
sink, but I would just
pop right back up.
And so what she was talking
about, releasing all of the air
was a challenge to do that
and feel like I'm not going
to run out of air underwater.
But the more you
did it, the more you
realized that it was--
it made it easier
to stay relaxed underwater
to let that all out.
And you can sink and
really just relax.
So that was surprising and
a little bit of a struggle
to remember that and try not
to make my face do the fish.
And "Oh, open your eyes."
And you know, "Oh, here,
and there's fabric,"
and struggling with that.
But once I kind of calmed
down about the whole thing,
it just became easy
because of the water made
everything fluid and movable.
ERENA SHIMODA: Yeah.
And the water
temperature helps a lot
because this pool was indoor
heated and 92 degrees.
And you almost don't want
to come out from the water.
[LAUGHS] And I've worked with
so many different temperatures
of the pool.
And a cold one,
they cannot smile.
Their shoulders are
up, and you're cramped.
And you try to smile with it,
and it's just not natural.
So the temperature, I always
ask whenever I look for a pool,
you need to be in
a certain number.
And this one was really easy.
AUDIENCE: Erena, you mentioned
a little bit about survivor's
guilt. And I think that's
becoming more of a topic
that we talk about.
But I thought it'd be
interesting to hear
from both of you, even your
perspectives on that guilt
that we feel when
we lose a loved one.
ERENA SHIMODA: First,
I didn't realize
that was causing my depression.
And also, it was for me to
accept it, to accept his death
to begin with.
And also, I was trying
to ignore my problem.
So when I started
to face that, this
was my major problem
that I am not
accepting and letting it go.
And I relied on the medications,
but it was not working for me.
And I was searching
and searching
for the better result.
And then I started to find
out all the other articles
about scuba diving and swimming.
And scuba diving is
my favorite sport.
And I can say it
was my first hobby.
So That's why I was so--
diving since then.
And I cannot do that
in San Francisco.
It's so cold.
And then you cannot
see anything.
Maybe Monterey when
it's really great.
Is there anybody
scuba divers here?
Yes.
But I highly recommend learning
scuba diving, whether here
or the diving destinations,
because you feel so free.
Just like when I told
you guys about Jared,
he's an army veteran
with disabilities.
And the water is the only place
that he doesn't feel any pain.
And I don't have the
physical pain like that,
but I certainly feel so much
relieved from the stress
or same thing as going into
the water or the hot tub.
You guys go to hot tub,
like a spa and hot tub.
In Asia, I grew up in Japan.
So almost every night,
we go into the baths.
And my father, I
remember he'd take a bath
to release all stress from
that day, like long hours.
And I really believe
that the water really
helps me so I could
drop those medications.
And then I'm still swimming
every day, almost every day.
So it is a way to
heal, to outlet,
to heal my survivor's guilt.
LAURIE RATLIFF:
Survivor's guilt is
something that crept up on me.
In the beginning,
especially since I
was diagnosed
metastatic, which means
that the cancer had
already spread to my bones
and my life expectancy
was actually
statistically not that long.
So every year that I went on, it
was great that I'm still here.
Yay.
But as more time went on--
and I would talk to other cancer
people who had been diagnosed.
And I would say, "Hey, I've
been here 10 years, 15 years."
It felt good because
I felt like I
could give them hope to say
see, sometimes people do survive
longer than they say you will.
But then it got
to a certain point
where I was afraid I was
giving people false hope.
And so many people that I had
met and heard about or just
talked to had passed
away, and I hadn't.
And there's no
explanation for it.
So I started to not
want to talk about it
and not want to tell
people how long I'd
been a survivor because you
get that question of why me?
Why me?
So it's something I'm
dealing with right now.
And I'm finding it
very difficult to--
I'm happy to be
alive, of course.
But there's also
that sense of people
lose so many people to cancer
that I worry that I remind
people that they lost someone.
So it's an ongoing struggle.
But this is also had
been part of the process,
and this really helps
too is asking about it,
because that's a tough subject.
Because most people will say,
"Just be happy you're alive."
And it's like it's
not that simple.
AUDIENCE: In relation
to therapy and also
kind of your pathway
specifically, Erena,
in kind of searching for what's
broken about me, I'm curious,
does underwater
therapy produce a place
of more openness with speaking?
And is that part of
the goal in undergoing
different kinds of therapy?
Mostly because in, say, like
Asian or Asian-American spaces,
maybe discussion and
openness around words
is not as available or people
don't have the same tool set.
So I'm curious.
Maybe it's a two parter.
One, for you, what was
your therapy journey?
And would you have
done it differently?
And two, have you found that
Asian or Asian-American clients
have a lot more joy and healing
through underwater therapy?
ERENA SHIMODA: I cannot
really compare from other
nationalities.
But it was-- hmm.
I think they're all equal.
Everybody's different,
regardless of how
what you are, depends
on a temperature.
But also how you grew up
and how you were reacting.
Like Drina hasn't
been in the water
deeper than her knee
level, or the people who
are just swimmer.
They thought they can do it all.
But actually, all the swimmers,
they had all the confidence,
but sinking down vertically was
completely different than what
swimmers would do.
So they were struggling
submerging underwater.
So I know that everybody
has different backgrounds.
But the first 5,
10 minutes, we all
struggle because it's a new
space, and it's a surprise.
Because in a picture like this,
you think you can do this,
right?
You can do it.
And it looks so easy.
But actually, when you are
in the water and sink down,
it depends on the
muscle mass too.
The muscle is heavy like weight.
So you can sink more.
But sometimes you can't.
So the first 5, 10 minutes
is a struggle for everybody
to adjust in a different world.
And then after the
10 minutes, everybody
has the similar transformation,
next transformative experience.
And everybody has the different
types of transformation.
And my goal is to see them
smile after the photo sessions,
or see that when I show them the
preview photos from my camera,
I want them to laugh.
That's my goal.
Because laughing is really
important for our lives.
Even just to watch
movies and laugh.
And the laughing-- these
days, we're so busy.
We're not even
having your own time.
And being underwater, I am
providing you a space for you
to have fun and free.
AUDIENCE: She's asking
about your therapy journey
and looking back, if you would
have done anything differently.
ERENA SHIMODA: I cannot think
of anything else to do because I
love water.
After I discovered scuba diving,
I knew that was the only place
I can meditate because
I'm usually spazzy,
and I cannot stay in one spot.
But underwater, all
the noise block,
and you hear all
the white noise,
and you can focus on yourself.
And after I found out that
space, I thought, "OK,
this is it."
Then since then, I haven't
looked for anything.
I do yoga.
And yoga helps.
Depends on the teacher.
[LAUGHS] But yeah.
I think other than that,
I haven't been looking.
I'm just focused on
swimming every day.
AUDIENCE: I guess in terms
of creating the photo sets,
do you have an idea
of a theme beforehand?
Or does one sort of
present itself afterwards?
I guess this shot
and the previous one,
there seem to be abstract hearts
withing her shape of her there
and the fabric in
the previous slide.
So was that on purpose
or happy accident?
LAURIE RATLIFF: Happy
accident, I think.
I had not noticed that.
ERENA SHIMODA: Yeah.
Yeah, it looks like heart.
Things are moving in
the water constantly,
and it's hard to say, "Can you
do this, and can you do that?"
Especially with the fabrics,
it's moving like wavy motions.
And always, I want
them to be themselves.
And I don't usually
tell them what
to do because this
is a place that they
can be free and be themselves.
So I asked her to just do
whatever you want to do.
Just let me know.
AUDIENCE: How does
a conversation
kind of go with the client
when this kind of planning
of what kind of
clothing to bring,
or props, or lack
for a better word,
I guess sometimes people might
wear makeup or something.
But then what if that runs
underwater or something?
You know, things like that.
You know, how does
that conversation go?
ERENA SHIMODA: Yeah.
So I do have that conversation
on Skype or in person
so that we can trust each
other, because in the water,
we can't talk or communicate.
So I would like
to get that trust
before and outside the water.
And the question is usually
like the makeup and also a dress
or where they can get.
And the makeup-wise,
it's really up to them.
Sometimes they don't
want to wear anything.
They want to go natural.
And that's totally fine.
It's their choice.
And if they want
to wear something--
and I have the basic ones.
And they're all usually from
the theatrical makeup store.
There's one in San Francisco.
And it's water resistant.
It just don't smear your face.
But other than that,
it doesn't come off.
And I let them wear
it by themselves,
or I apply on their face
just like the basic ones.
Or they do like
to get their own.
So that's part of their process
to have fun and go shopping.
And you can go get the
clothes from the thrift store.
You can damage it because
it's cheaper than buying
the expensive new clothes.
So I want them to have
fun for this process
and to pump up for
the photo shoot.
AUDIENCE: The first
photos you had
with those motion photography,
how did you do those?
Is it like an overlay
animation on top of a photo?
The water was all moving,
but the people were still.
ERENA SHIMODA: Oh, yes.
I used the app
called Plotograph.
And you can download
it on your phone,
but I used the browser version.
And you use your flat image
and put the effects on it.
And it's pretty good for
the marketing and imagery.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Please join me in giving
a big round of applause
for both Erena and for Laurie.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]